i mean chess is so popular in india and
uh you know if you were 16 and doing
this in england it wouldn't get noticed
really well is there some sorry i just
got distracted by the those pawns i mean
you can go f3 here i i guess just lock
it up block it up just don't give any
chances look at this poor black king it
just can't get into the white half of
the board and ding it
yeah it's over it's over yeah white's
king just needs to go and attack this
black rook the white pawn is going to
cost black his rook
yeah it's just way too slow now you can
just push this pawn forward black is far
too slow in this race he's gonna give
some checks force the white king away
but
it's hopeless now yeah
i you know this is gonna be really hard
for dink because maybe you know his his
strategy is seemed to be play super
solid but what happens when you lose a
game like that
you know you can't play super solid in
the next game
and is that it i think we have it it's
over
pragnanda the 16 year old he makes a
comeback ding just covers up his camera
prague is now in the